Russian painter kazimir Malevich wanted
to liberate art from the weight of
things he was 36 when he secured his
place in art history did kunst mph on
his aim was to liberate art from its
task of representing reality that's not
what he thought it was for he wanted it
to form its own reality Valley Tate
buildin radical art to radical times the
first world war was raging in Russia
revolution would soon be in the air the
revolution was also underway in arts
Malevich brazenly hunk is painting in
the upper corner of the room the place
where Orthodox icons were traditionally
located Malevich called his work
suprematism because it was based upon
the supremacy of pure artistic feeling
he was equally radical in his approach
to sculpture and even to designing tea
sets under Stalin abstract art fell out
of favor twenty years after painting his
electrifying black square he was forced
to swim with the tide and to turn his
hand to a state sanctioned socialist
realism Malevich died in 1935 his grave
was marked with a black square
in the Soviet Union his early work was
officially derided but its influence
lived on the blacks where it changed the
way we think about art forever